so is this a uk specific issue or is
this title suggests a global supply
crisis well certainly there are some uk
specific factors going on here brexit a
shortage of hgv drivers but there's also
something big happening behind the
scenes and that comes down to this this
is gross domestic product so global
growth the amount of national income uh
created in each country and what you've
got here is the average annual growth
that we've seen in these countries from
japan through to the uk the g7
industrialized economies that's the
average over recent years but now look
at what's expected this year so these
are the latest forecasts just out from
the international monetary fund and look
at how high those bars are the uk in
particular 6.8 that's the highest that
we've seen on record but it's not just
the uk the us is very strong as well and
france and italy again the highest on
record we're just not used to seeing
this much growth in the global economy a
lot of demand it's not just about supply
it's about demand and there's masses out
there and that is feeding into shipping
and when you look it's not just felix
though although we just saw felix though
there's there is some congestion around
the port there
we've seen it in other places as well in
recent months we saw it in l.a the port
of los angeles you had some serious
congestion over there and on the other
side of the world as well if we sweep
across there uh in ningbo so that's the
main port for shanghai one of the most
important ports in the world and they've
had serious congestion there as well and
it's not just in you know you can look
at two at a different metric it's called
the baltic dry index which gives you a
sense of across the world what the
demand is for shipping the higher this
line is the more demand there is and
this line too if i just kind of zoom
back a little bit through into history
you can see that line's now at the
highest level since 2008 so we're
talking about a lot of demand for
shipping a lot of demand for goods and
that in turn is pushing up prices so the
uk we know that inflation is pretty high
in the uk 3.2 but just have a look at
this we just got numbers out from the us
and that inflation in the u.s is at the
highest level in 13 years 5.4 percent
cpi uh in the u.s higher than expected
so higher prices more demand problems in
shipping is happening all over the world